[Música]
comenzamos una nueva emisión de
reporteros gracias por estar con
nosotros el tema de hoy es la penuria
por la que deben pasar miles de
inmigrantes en francia a la hora de
querer establecerse en el país las
asociaciones de asistencia a los
extranjeros denuncian una lógica de
desaliento para restringir el flujo
migratorio en francia cada vez que un
extranjero quiere establecerse en el
país debe solicitar un permiso de
residencia en una de las 101 prefecturas
existentes una entidad territorial como
una ciudad o una provincia la cita debe
solicitarse desde 2016 por internet y a
veces es necesario esperar incluso
varios meses para obtenerla con lo que
se corre el riesgo de encontrar una
situación irregular ser arrestado y
trasladado a un centro de detención para
extranjeros antes de una posible
deportación en la siguiente historia les
traemos las voces de algunos de los
300.000 indocumentados que viven en
francia tratando de obtener un permiso
de residencia
[Música]
o no
esta mañana un centenar de personas se
manifiesta frente al tribunal
administrativo de montroi entre ellos
abogados y sus clientes extranjeros
indocumentados oa la espera de una
renovación de hecho nosotros los
abogados terminamos ejerciendo un oficio
que no era nuestro tener que ser
contencioso para permitirles a los
extranjeros obtener una cita es decir
para permitirles obtener un servicio
público que ofrece un servicio público
desde 2016 los extranjeros deben
registrarse en línea obligatoriamente en
las páginas de las prefecturas para
obtener o renovar un permiso de estadía
los abogados denuncian estas nuevas
reglas de atribución de citas y
predicamos montané a mente 50 recursos
en varios tribunales de isla de francia
el objetivo es obligar a las prefecturas
a expedir las citas a personas que hoy
en día no pueden obtenerlas en línea
esta desmaterialización había sido
puesta en marcha para ponerle fin a las
filas frente a las prefecturas hoy en
día las filas se trasladaron a los
computadores para tratar de obtener una
cita tanto de día como de noche
massa nye conoce esta situación bastante
bien
esta joven marfileñas era mayor de edad
muy pronto erradicar una solicitud de
permiso de estadía antes de su
cumpleaños pero la página de la
prefectura está saturada desde hace
varios meses
hago capturas de pantalla todo el tiempo
cada noche con frecuencia me despierto a
media noche 4 de la mañana 6 de la
mañana siempre me dicen que no hay
disponibilidad es como si estuviese
presa quiero ser como los demás quiero
obtener una cita quiero tener un permiso
de estadía para poder trabajar mi jefe
dice que si estoy indocumentada no podrá
contratarme porque no puede trabajar con
indocumentados pero tengo coraje y hago
mi esfuerzo aunque siempre pasa lo mismo
todos los días me dicen que no hay
disponibilidad
los abogados dicen que los casos como el
de más aunque abundan
desde hace tiempo obtener una cita en
una prefectura es una pesadilla
antes los extranjeros pasaban la noche
entera a las afueras de las oficinas con
la esperanza de ser recibidos a la hora
de apertura para eliminar estas filas de
espera interminable desde hace tres años
el 80% de las prefecturas francesas
eligieron de materializar las citas el
prefecto de son jean benoît albertini
puso en marcha este nuevo sistema en su
departamento en el 2019
se trata de una reforma de la manera en
que se reservan las citas una
simplificación de los procedimientos es
más fácil hacerlo en casa que esperar
aleatoriamente a las afueras de la
prefectura a veces con frío bajo lluvia
una hipotética cita con los turnos que
entregamos aquí
un éxito visible pero a medias el
servicio público es más eficaz en la era
de internet estas dificultades de
obtener citas en línea no denotan por el
contrario una voluntad política de
desmotivar a los extranjeros en francia
a 4,4 millones de inmigrantes cuenta con
un permiso de estadía
quienes no cuentan con uno viven en el
país sin papeles a veces desde años
es el caso de patrice hace seis años que
este marfileño de 42 años vive en
francia con su esposa e hija
siempre obtuve el mismo mensaje que no
hay disponibilidad
a inicios de 2018 pidió su
regularización tras una larga espera de
un año
la prefectura le contestó lo siguiente
debe primero sacar una cita por internet
debe iniciar todo de nuevo cuando se es
indocumentado con frecuencia estamos
obligados a hacerle el quite a la ley y
es muy difícil estar regularizado es muy
importante si decides vivir en este país
hay que respetar las normas pero si eres
indocumentado y debes alimentar a una
familia te ves obligado a hacerle el
quite a la ley trabajar como ilegal
300.000 indocumentados viven en francia
para que su expediente sea examinado
deben reunir un máximo de documento que
pruebe en su presencia en el territorio
francés cuento con una factura de
electricidad edf que está a mi nombre
con el apellido de la señora cuento con
la inscripción en la lista de espera de
mi hija para la guardería que es una de
las pruebas prueba de presencia en el
2016 prueba de presencia en el 2017
cuento con mi certificado de voluntario
que prueba que soy voluntario jiennense
curse católico
[Música]
tras nueve meses de intentos
infructuosos en la página de la
prefectura finalmente obtuvo su cita
[Música]
como hay
tras nueve meses estoy emocionado nueve
meses de intentos en la página hoy me
dicen que tengo una cita muy importante
demos curación
es el gran día acompañamos a patricia la
prefectura de nanterre en alta cena tras
dos horas de espera lo recibe un agente
grabamos la conversación con una cámara
escondida
[Música]
señor es la primera vez que solicita un
permiso de estadía sí de acuerdo tengo
todo voy a validar su expediente señor y
voy a emitir le una certificación de
erradicación con la que usted podrá
contar mientras decidimos la decisión
tomará más o menos un mes y medio o dos
meses
el señor esperaba una cita desde hace
nueve meses
sí efectivamente cómo es posible que
demore tanto para nosotros con el cambio
de procedimientos se restringen los
flujos porque de lo contrario no podemos
ocuparnos de todos los expedientes
entonces tomamos 40 expedientes
semanales máximo teniendo en cuenta que
no somos muchos agentes si queremos
garantizar plazos decentes y no que las
personas radiquen y esperen un año antes
de que sean citadas como ocurría antes y
en un momento dado hay que reducir los
flujos sería bueno emplear más agentes
facilite me los recursos si te ha
concedidas a cuentagotas un solo
funcionario disponible para estudiar
decenas de expedientes por semana una
situación banal en números a prefecturas
francesas puede circular con esto ok y
esperar la decisión de la prefectura de
acuerdo gracias hasta luego le agradezco
los recortes de presupuesto han hecho
que entre 2016 y 2019 las prefecturas
perdieran cerca de 1500 agentes
patricia obtuvo un recibo válido durante
seis meses tras años vividos con miedo
de un control ya puede circular
legalmente
es un descanso estoy emocional lo
esperaba hace tiempo
un largo recorrido no si no es fácil
es el inicio de un nuevo capítulo
si es de dos meses para ver para ser aún
más feliz
[Música]
unas semanas más tarde la perfectura le
entrega un permiso de estadía de dos
años siempre y cuando consiga un trabajo
para entender mejor esta nueva regla nos
dirigimos a la cima de una asociación de
ayuda para los extranjeros crearon un
robot informático que evalúa varias
veces al día la posibilidad de obtener
una cita en la prefectura el resultado
es elocuente en color negro las veces
que el robot no encontró ninguna cita
disponible
por ejemplo esta es la prefactura de
calvados en como mide en cierta forma la
tasa de apertura virtual de la sucursal
administrativa nos dice que si esta
pagina prefectoral fuese una sucursal de
76 por ciento de la semana permanecería
cerrada para los usuarios del servicio
público
quizá faron ha alertado desde hace años
sobre esta situación para ella la
imposibilidad de tomar una cita en línea
se explica por cualquier otra cosa minus
y lázaro asumimos al vecino del pont se
confiesa todo
es alucinante que sea necesario esperar
seis meses un año dos años para
erradicar una solicitud sabiendo que la
radicación de esta solicitud es una
obligación legal para las personas nos
encontramos frente a una lógica de
desmotivación que busca que las personas
bajen los brazos y decidan irse por
decisión propia
en esta lógica de la desmotivación es
rechazada por las prefecturas quiénes
son el robot de la cima le indica que en
más del 95% de los casos obtener una
cita es imposible para el perfecto esto
no es real
es una observación realizada por una
asociación no es nuestra observación no
confío en los robots así sepa qué ocurre
y que tengamos que hacer algunas mejoras
en el software de reservas es un trabajo
del ministerio del interior para evitar
que algunos particulares use el robot
para obtener citas en detrimento de
otros usuarios
frente a la escasez de citas una especie
de tráfico se puso en marcha en ciertos
cibercafés a cambio de un puñado de
euros se hace un seguimiento en internet
el dueño de este comercio solo se ocupa
de las renovaciones de permisos de
estadía
[Música]
tuvimos una cita para enero y su cita es
el 11 de marzo solo este servicio
cobramos diez euros tan sólo por la
renovación
10 euros la cita más solidaridad que
negocio página de internet facebook
numerosos aprovechados proponen una
reventa de citas ante la prefectura
e
[Música]
contactamos a uno de los revendedores
con el fin de obtener una cita para un
primer permiso de estadía nos pide 300
euros para las prefecturas este mercado
paralelo explica las dificultades para
obtener una cita en línea sin embargo
según los revendedores no se trata de
complicidades internas o software
informático todo es artesanal se turnan
en las páginas de las prefecturas y
actualizan constantemente las páginas de
citas hasta que ciertos horarios se
liberan mientras esperan una cita los
extranjeros que viven en francia como
ilegales viven con el miedo de ser
expulsados en cualquier momento en el
centro de retención de maryland blog en
la periferia de parís nos reunimos con
un extranjero indocumentado aquí están
prohibidos tanto los teléfonos como las
cámaras grabamos con cámara escondida
utiliza el senegalés vive en francia
desde hace 8 años con su esposa y sus
tres hijos nacidos aquí ha tratado de
obtener una cita en la perfectura desde
hace más de un año
hace poco fue controlado en el bus sin
ticket de transporte lo llevaron a la
comisaría
al centro de retención
si lo expulsan a senegal cuáles son las
consecuencias para su familia
[Música]
y las consecuencias inmediatas son que
mis hijas si permanecen aquí morirán de
hambre eso es seguro el segundo problema
es que estaré separado de ellas he
estado aquí durante dos semanas algo que
nunca me había sucedido no me han visto
me veo obligado a mentirles a decirles
que estoy de viaje no quiero que me
visiten y nunca ha estado detenido tengo
33 años y siempre he hecho lo necesario
para vivir correctamente supongamos que
regreso a senegal habré perdido ocho
años de mi vida ocho años de sacrificios
ocho años de retenciones
y me pongo
cada año el gobierno crea nuevos puestos
en estos centros francia es el país
europeo que cuenta con el récord de
encierros de extranjeros
marion bofill abogada de la cima de
observa un endurecimiento de los
procedimientos contra los indocumentados
como índice
la prefectura fue muy severa porque
decidieron encerrarlo en el centro de
retención además de la decisión de
expulsarlo con el pretexto de que era
una amenaza para el orden público y eso
lo deciden con base en la trampa para
subirse a lanús mientras que en realidad
las personas que amenazan el orden
público son personas condenadas que han
ido a prisión el endurecimiento al que
asistimos es un hecho desde hace dos
años y medio para tratar de hacer la
relación con los cambios políticos hoy
en día lo asumen tanto a nivel
gubernamental ministerio del interior
como a nivel de las prefecturas que
reciben las directivas se trata de una
política de control de todo y de
encierro entonces vemos que encierran
gente que antes no era retenida
dos semanas después de nuestra
entrevista utiliza fue expulsado a
senegal el 2019 la cantidad de
expulsiones aumentó en un 20% con
respecto al 2010
el presidente de emanuel macrón decidio
desmaterializar todos los trámites
administrativos de aquí a 2022
gracias por habernos acompañado en esta
emisión de reporteros recuerde que puede
ingresar a nuestra página web france24
puntocom para ver esta emisión y las
anteriores hasta la próxima semana